ああっん
だーうだったっては感がは困難
スピーダーやなぁこず遺憾だいたやつ
ブーバー様々なぬーんっ
いやで件ああ
あーおれでパレ java ファッションの修行後10年間積んできたわけだから
まあおしゃれに感謝は人一倍こう先生方が中かなその日のうちにトレンドのまあ5年先
までのトレンドがだいたい見極めるというかまあそういう感じのスキルを持って術中
まあある以下の日本に帰って人って言えば経歴の持ち主的な振っツイーター今の日本人
が殺傷でその皆無だね全然アラン
とび張って言うなんか日本勢はこうなんかみんな同じ格好をしたい
自分だしきれないわけようん日本勢お前たぜ全体的にまあまあファッションのことを
教えていこうと思ってる
モテるモテないと過疎技ばいいんだ大事なのは自分の好きな格好をするということあと
まあ人と同じだなれば柳井正尚
入っといてまぁ今日はなぁ今からでも何のできるようなお洒落ってもんでちょっと
教えようと思う
誰でも出来る簡単なされたいならまず救いとかどうでもいいんだよ大事なところは
もっとこのないところから走れないと誰でも簡単に変えられるところがまぁあれだ
アクセサリーとそういう分野でまぁ一番手っ取り前のかっ腕腕円筒形
プレイするとマーサ
ドラゴンがあると思うけどもいい
薪を使うなこれがラバーリングながリングなってるのこれ
なぜバカんだよパターン触れセットかなラバーブレスレットだと思うとラバー
ブレスレットモナーの腕につけていくこともこれは今日ここに100個買ってきたから
100で2通常盤まあそれだけどねまぁ見たらすると思うからこういう奴な
こういうやつこれがバーブレスを8月あ
だけシャっとしていくことも百貨も付ければ目立つ子やっぱオリジナリティとか出る
から基本的には100個付けちゃえばいいなって所ある
誰でも簡単にできる
これ一個つけるだけであればファッションのアクセントになるん
ピアノ柄でね音楽好きアピールをして
音楽関係の人との出会いを繋がれるガンつけていけばいいところあるてっこねぇいいと
思う
あの10個付けた時点ではこんな感じだ中の方されだろ
ああっ
ちょっと痛いな
あ20個目だ
まあ20個つけたらまぁこんな感じだちょうど行こう
言えば星ぬヤヴァくおえうえーーー i +マナー
30個つけたらこんな感じがちょっと皮膚が痛い下剤がこれぐらいが束縛されている間
はペルできる
となんてそもそも病ちょっとだったらこれショップつけば死ぬまとぶん
いたちょっと待ってればん
をしています
ブーツ
はい台ちょっと違うなっている
ちょっとまずいなぜこうだめだちょっと行けトロ
よってシムカチの腕の色がこれ腕の色でマーチ熱ドンちょっと山ねばいばい
rar
ザックっ
wh
バッハ
はぁ
してません
こんなはずじゃなかったらちょっと待ってこんなはずじゃなかった津希
何がやりたいかわからなかった
ana ん
ran ん
then